let's say that company ABCD is some type
of a pharmaceutical company that has a
drug trial coming out and you're
convinced it's right now trading at $50
this year but you're convinced that if
the drug gets approved that the
company's stock is going to skyrocket
and you're also convinced that if the
companies if the drug gets rejected that
the the stock price is going to tank to
maybe five or ten dollars so if you
wanted to make money off of that belief
and I'm not necessarily recommending
that you do it's always trickier in
reality than it sounds on paper but one
way that you could is you could actually
buy both the call option and the put
option on that stock the put option is
going to make you money if the stock
tanks and then the call option is going
to make money if the stock becomes if
the drug gets approved and the stock
skyrocket so let's just actually draw
the payoff diagram here so if the stock
goes down if the stock goes down just
let's say it goes down to zero you would
exercise the put option because you
could buy the stock for zero exercise
your put option and sell it for $50 this
is the right to sell the stock for $50
and of course we're talking about the
value of the of the combination now at
expiration at expiration so if the stock
is worth zero at expiration the value of
the put option is worth fifty the call
option is clearly worthless you wouldn't
exercise the call option if the stock is
worth zero you wouldn't want to buy
something for $50 that's worth a zero so
from from the stock of being worth zero
all the way up to the stock being worth
fifty you would want to exercise you
would want to exercise the put option
but the value of the put option is going
to become lower and lower and lower and
anything above fifty you wouldn't
exercise the put option at all but if
you get above fifty you would want to
exercise your call option if the stock
is worth $60 at expiration then your
call option is worth ten because you
have the right to buy something for 50
which you can sell for 60 so then you
have the value of your call option going
up so you can see a situation here when
you just think about the value of this
bundle of the call plus the put option
that it's not much value if the stock
doesn't if the if the value of the stock
doesn't change from 50 your your your
options are worthless but if you have a
major movement either to the upside or
the downside
then this straddle it's called let me
write that down when you buy when you go
long as a call and you go long and put
this is called a long straddle and a
long trial you benefit from a major
price movement and when you think about
from the profit and loss point of view
you just shift it down based on the
amount that you paid for the two options
so in this case we paid we paid $20 for
both options so in this situation where
we would exercise the foot instead of
making $50 we have to net it for the $20
we paid for the options so we would only
make $30 and at the point where we're
not exercising either option because
we're really they're both they're both
essentially worthless we're not going to
no reason to exercise them then we
essentially have just lost $20 for both
options so we will be down over here and
then anything above $50 anything above
$50 will start to make money so let me
draw the option diagram over here and
look it will look like this it will look
like this the payoff diagram it will
look just it will look just like that so
when you actually factor in how much you
paid for the options you now see that
you only would make money with this
straddle if the underlying stock price
maybe after the the results of the trial
or at least hopefully they get released
before the maturity of the actual
options if the stock goes below if the
stock goes in this area if the stock
goes below $30 or if the stock goes
above $70 but if it has one of those
major movements then this position this
straddle this long straddle will make
you money